foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the students of the class of 2023
and their parents families and friends
welcome to the
322nd commencement of Yale University We
Salute your effort your diligence your
talent and your intellect I now ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the bachelor's degrees in Yale
College
as designated by the dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
Mr President I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees in the David
Geffen School of drama the School of
Architecture in the School of Nursing
[Applause]
thank you